Okay, welcome everyone to lecture number
nine of the course. So
we are in the last third if you could
say that. Okay, so what have we learned
so far? Just [clears throat] revising a
little bit. So our aim is to learn PTEs
or rather the solution operators of PDS
from data. And to do that we are going
to use operator learning and we have
seen lots and lots of different examples
of that. Now FNO convolutional operator
vision transformer scalable operator
transformer and the list goes on. And
what we saw in the last lecture is that
as long as you are on a cartisian domain
in 2D so you know squares then this is
fine because we essentially treat it as
images and process them accordingly. But
there are many caveats and in the next
four lectures that I have what I'm going
to do is to focus on those caveats and
try to explain how these can be overcome
how these difficulties can be overcome
how these problems can be remedied.
Right? So what are these caveats? So
let's start with the very first one
which is on the next slide and that is
going to be the issue of time dependent
PDS. So we have already considered time
dependent PDS right it's not like we
haven't considered if you remember Navia
Stokes is very much a time dependent PD
I'm not going to write down the
equations but it's a very much a time
dependent PDE but what we did is that
our solution operator
given the initial data you not what it
did is that it mapped it to some
solution at a later time or solution at
a final time E of T right so you start
initially and you try to predict what
happens um at time t equal to 1 in 1
hour or 1 day or whatever uh is a time
scale that you're considering and this
is exactly sort of the mode in which our
models our AI models are deployed right
that we [snorts] start with some initial
conditions and then we say what is the
solution at a later time which is okay
because it's exactly the same sort of
throughput as what happens if you take a
steady state equation for instance a
pson equation [snorts] and then the
solution operator was simply a mapping
from the forcing term to the solution
because there is no time now so it's
mapping forcing term to the solution so
we are essentially treating a time
dependent PD so this is time dependent
and this one is time independent in the
same manner we didn't really
differentiate between them is that clear
so we took uh some input which could be
a forcing term which could be a
coefficient which could be an initial
condition and we mapped it to an output
which could also be which could be the
solution for a steady state PD P or it
could be the solution at a later time
for a time dependent PD and we really
didn't distinguish between them but in
practice there is a difference right
because there between the two we have a
distinction and this distinction is
essentially given by the arrow of time
time is a very special dimension it's
not exactly the same as uh as the
spatial dimensions right and time
dependent PDEs have their own special
properties so what we are going to
concentrate in the beginning of today's
lecture is how we can treat time
dependent PTE where the mapping might be
more complicated than just going from
the initial conditions to the final
time. Okay, so let's try to focus on
that. Everyone understood the objective.
It's sort of a very clear objective.
What are the differences and how we take
into account these differences? Okay. So
now let's focus. We have to sort of
start with some math. [snorts]
So now time dependent PDS have a very
abstract or the most abstract form we
can write them like this. You can think
of the Navia Stokes equation. So the
momentum equation would be UT plus U dot
grad u plus the gradient of P equals to
zero. So this is an Atos equation. I'm
not writing the continuity equation.
It's implicit. Okay. So then so you have
a differential operator L which is a
function of X a function of U a function
of X T function of U and its derivatives
right so here for instance the first
derivatives of the Nav I wrote the Oiler
equations the Navia Stokes equations
would have the viscosity so mu llassian
of U so the derivatives the gradients of
U spatial gradients not temporal
gradients right I [snorts] did not use
high order derivatives in time for
instance in the wave equation you have
two derivatives in time but to me that
is not an issue. Can you tell me why I
can take any derivatives in time and I
still only need to consider the sort of
the first order derivative in time. Can
anyone tell me why?
So in other words, what is the
connection between this equation and the
wave equation? UT minus C^² LLAN of U=0.
Right? So here there is a second
derivative in time. But I say that all
the equations with second, third, fourth
derivatives in time I can subsume them
in this form.
Is that clear why this can be done?
Yeah,
>> you can create a system.
>> Yeah, exactly. So what you could do is
that you create a system. So this is
what you might have learned in ODEs that
all that you you might have 10 10th
order derivatives. It rarely happens
that we look at 10th order derivatives
in time. Usually look at the first
derivative which is usually the velocity
of displacement. Second derivative is
acceleration. Rarely is a PD with a
third derivative in time. There are some
esoteric ones but they are very very
rare. But what you do is that you just
write them out as a system, right?
Because I never told you what is the
dimension of you. This could be a
vector. So this is so you make the
displacement
uh unknown and you make the velocity an
unknown and then you can do that. Right?
So this is the abstract form that works
for almost all time dependent BDS. There
are some exceptions but uh this is this
is the abstract form that you'll work
with. Now [snorts] the solution operator
in this case the more tricky thing it's
not just the mapping between the input
and the output as you saw here but it
has to take time into consideration
right that's why I said that time is a
special variable so what it is is that I
need a function space right because my
initial conditions for instance live in
the function space I'm saying that my
boundary conditions are fixed just to
just to make our life simple because it
also depends on the boundary conditions
and so on but the initial conditions are
in the function space X. So the mapping
you expect that it's not always the case
but you expect that if you start with
the function space you remain in the
function space and this is a simplified
situation it often happens like that.
Okay. So what you do is that this is a
function of time [snorts]
and of the initial condition and given
the time given the initial condition
given what is called a lead time t= 1
t=2 t= 10
what you want want the solution operator
to map is to go to the solution at that
particular time span okay so this is the
solution operator of a time dependent PE
it depends on time itself and not just
on the input right so it's a function
it's a time dependent function or time
dependent operator rather and in
particular as you can imagine what
happens is that there is causality there
is a march in time right we can always
march in time you'll see that
graphically in the next slide so what
what happens is or maybe I can already
[snorts]
sort of show you so you start with some
initial conditions so you have let's
let's look at this so this is time
right and we start with some initial
conditions this could be something like
this Then you go to a later time. This
could be something like this. So this is
t=0. This is t= 1. Then you march on t =
2. This could be something even flatter.
Who knows what happens, right? So this
is how the solution it's like a video,
right? The solution keeps on evolving in
time. And the point is that to find the
solution at t equal to two, there are
different things that you can do. You
can for instance say that I start with
the initial condition. Right? So I start
with the initial condition and I go all
the way to t = 2. So in other words to
get u at 2, I can take s put two as my
time and start with u at zero. This is
one possibility. But on the other hand
we know that this solution operator is
what is called a semigroup. So what I
can also do is I can go like this. I can
start at t equal to 1 and then march one
in time. So u2 is also given by 1 and u
at one
right agreed. So there is this
causality. So things are causal in the
sense that the past determines the
future. Right? So to reach here I can
either you give me the initial
conditions and I can march all the way
forward or you just give me the initial
conditions or give me the conditions at
t equal to 1 and then I march one step
forward or one time forward. Okay. So
all and there are many many infinitely
many com or uncountably many
combinations that you can think of.
Okay, is that clear? So this will play a
very vital role in what I'm going to
say. So it's important to understand
that. So in other words, for any time
increment, this is why I said for any
time increment t delta t you can march
forward in time and the operator takes
you here. So once you know this operator
you can start initially and you can go
to any time or but you can also start at
any time and go to any forward time.
Okay. So it's always forward causal.
Some systems are time reverse. So you
can also come back in time but most
systems are not like that. So using the
weather today you can predict the
weather tomorrow but uh the other way
around is difficult because uh the
weather has some non-reversible
irreversible effects. But this is this
is an important distinction right. So
the data for a time dependent problem
just think about whether for instance
can be when we when we generate the data
either by numerical simulations or by
observation it is a bit more subtle. So
we have an initial condition and we want
to find the solution at a later time.
But to get that solution at a later time
we get give the entire what is called a
trajectory. So you have u of t1 u of t2
all these time bins or in other words if
you look at my picture here [snorts] the
data is not just so when I march forward
and observe a system in time I don't
just observe the solution at a
particular instance I observe it along
the entire trajectory along in principle
all points in time but in practice of
course we cannot store at every single
time point we can only store at a
discrete set of potentially uh homo
heterogeneous unrelated time points But
the data could be let's march forward. T
equal to three. And then now I'm running
out of colors. Green is not a good
color.
So let's go to presets and let's use a
dark blue. So it could be something very
very pointed. Something like this.
Right? So you have this entire
collection of data and whether you
observe or whether you simulate you are
not left with just one data pair. You
are left with this entire trajectory.
Okay? So this [clears throat] is the
entire trajectory.
which is given here and you can think of
it as solution at t t t t t t t t t t t
t t t t t t t t t t t t t t t t t t t
t1, solution at t2 solution at final
time and so on. You can also think of it
in this time marching manner. So the
data for a time dependent problem is in
a way richer and in a way has more
structure to it than data for a steady
state problem because in a steady state
problem you just give the inputs,
boundary conditions, coefficients and
you read off the solution. For a time
dependent problem it's more complex. So
you get the initial condition, boundary
condition, coefficients, parameters and
you read out this entire trajectory.
Okay. So there is first of all more
volume of data, more to deal with but
more to play with. Right? So this is an
important distinction. So remember that
that already there is a big distinction
between the two in terms of the data
acquisition and in terms of the data
handling because there's much more data
in a time dep much much much more data
in a time dependent problem. For
instance, I can tell you about the
weather data that we have. Uh I don't
know if you'll have the time to explain
that, but the weather data is very high
quality observational data. It's called
error reanalysis data. And this is every
depends on what data set you're looking
at. But essentially you can say every
hour, okay, of the state of the global
weather or every 6 hours for sure, but
every hour from 1970s
let's say to now. So 50 years of data
but the data is uh stored at every
hourly interval or 6 hourly intervals.
So there are four data points a day 365
days a year. So you can do it's like uh
1,500 uh data points or 1,500 images or
snapshots you could think of and over 50
years. So it's a lot of data. So that's
why and there are various various
variables, right? So it's essentially
like uh many many pabytes of data. So
this is a much more datari problem. But
of course the task itself is harder
because what will be the operator
learning task the operator learning task
as you as I've written down below is
given my initial conditions given my
boundary conditions which is of course
implicit I did not write them down for
notational brevity then you have to
generate just like if you have a PD
solver PD simulator given the initial
conditions and boundary conditions it
can generate the entire trajectory okay
it can generate the entire trajectory
you require the same requirement Now so
you generate the entire solution
trajectory for all times t okay so in
principle all times in practice this
will be a discrete set of times we could
interpolate so in a way there is also
continuity in time right it's not just
this is why I wrote down it's continuous
in time not just in space so remember
one of the points about operator
learning was that you just don't look at
uh vectors uh discrete versions of
functions but you want to sample the
entire function itself in space. For a
time dependent problem, you have to
sample the entire function not just in
space but in time. Okay, both. So you
have essentially the entire trajectory
of the of the solution. And this is why
the task is hard harder in some sense
because not only do you have to you've
just been given the initial data
boundary conditions, you generate the
entire trajectory, the whole video or uh
right. So is this clear? Are there any
questions here? because the difficulty
of the task as well as what we have to
deal with is different. So I'm happy to
take questions at this juncture. No,
everyone understands. Okay, good. So now
this is the structure. This is the
system. Let me give you a concrete
example so that you understand what's
going on graphically. So this is the
example I on I think one of you answered
this question. So we took the wave
equation, right? So this is a concrete
well it's a toy model. uh we can we can
show you some real models later on but
this is a concrete toy model. So what
you have is you have uh just imagine
that you have um under the under the
ground and you generate explosions for
instance uh by detonating right this is
very common we have to do that for
instance to excavate mines or imagine
that these are small earthquakes so this
is how your ground looks like right rock
so this is different layers of rock so
you have different material properties
so this C here is a function of X and it
has a structure it's a variation in ex
space and time in space not in time
right it changes very very very slowly
in time means it changes over millions
of years but if you want to make some
explosions under the ground this is in
the time scale of seconds right and then
you set off then this is there so
there's a coefficient this is one of the
inputs C the other input is the initial
condition you not right so these are the
different points at which this waves are
generated and then you the system
[clears throat] is sent into the wave
equation the evolution of the wave
equation and you make different
observations right [snorts]
so delta t is not a small time it is
some non-dimensional time that I have
lead time that I put in so in the
beginning you can see that the waves
initially the waves are spreading they
are starting to interact at t equal to 2
delta t the waves these two waves meet
they start to interact at t equal to 3
the three waves meet at t equal to 4 the
four waves meet and so on and so forth
so this is going to be so your data
that. So remember that what is our
operator learning task? So we are doing
going to
operator learning here. So what is my
what is my task?
My task is this is important given you
not this is the initial data and the
coefficient C because it uh the property
depends on the coefficient C learn
ST.
Okay, let me write it like this or I
didn't write it the right way.
So s this is the solution operator at
any given time t given you not and c. So
this is going to be my my task in a way,
right? So I have to learn the operator
at any time t. And what is the data?
data is uh you put uh a probability
distribution
mu
making a lot of mistakes in writing
things. So now you put it's a
probability distribution on I don't know
u0x cross c. So these are some function
spaces that I have taken into account
sample samples. So these are u i the iat
sample ci the iat sample and
trajectories right. So this is U at T1
I,
U at T2 I and so on till U at TKI.
So this is going to be my data set,
right? So I and I is the variable one
less than I less than N and K is the
number of points that I can observe per
sample. So each of these so look at the
difficulty here. Each of these guys is a
function, right? It depends on space.
It's a function and the number of times
that we can observe depends on the
numerical solver that we have depends on
the storage facilities that we have
depends on the observational systems
that we have and the times at which you
observe might not be the same right they
they could be very very different we do
an experiment here someone does an
experiment and burn they might the
measurement apparatus could be very very
different so this is going to be my data
this is in this form it's in the form of
these trajectories and I have to learn
this entire solution operator at any
given time. Okay, so is the operator
learning task clear?
Okay, good. So now how do we solve this?
Right. So remember there is a
qualitative difference between the time
independent case because in the time
independent case you did not have this
pesky parameter which is this causal
structure. It's not just some random
structure. It's a causal structure and
your data was much more sparse in a way.
this is more dense data. Okay. So in
principle and this is an important point
that I want to emphasize sometimes you
know people don't understand this that
uh
[clears throat] this is the operator
learning task that this is the only
wellos operator that given the initial
conditions given the boundary conditions
and coefficients the solution operator
of the PD is well posted often what
people do and in the vast majority of
cases what people do is that they say no
no we are not going to do this since we
have this time information we say that
we have let's say 100 time steps we will
generate 50 time steps and then we'll
predict the next 50 okay and this is a I
would say even a crime in this in this
sense because numerical this is not a
wellposed problem for the weather system
it is okay perhaps because you have
constant stream of data that is coming
in but for most applications you will
not be given this uh rich set that you
already have a trajectory and then you
want to predict uh half the trajectory
and you want to predict the other half.
This is not a wellposed problem. What is
wellposed is from the starting point and
with the initial and boundary conditions
if you march on. Right? So this is what
is wellposed. But many people don't do
that. They say no no let's give half the
trajectory and we predict the remaining
half. That is not going to be that
useful. Huh? So it's sort of an
important distinction that that needs to
be made. Okay. So let me now try to
solve uh how we can address this. There
are different ways to address this uh
understandably and they're related to
what we have done before because the new
variable is of course time. We just have
to adjust how time is uh interpreted or
how time is used in this in this. Yes.
ask
>> and once I have this is it okay to apply
it kind of reversibly
>> yes yes yes absolutely this is what I'll
show you it's completely okay because
this operator is having this semigroup
property that given at as I told you
given at any so I need not in principle
once you have this operator to go up to
here it's enough if I start here right
because then I can either go here and
then here or I can directly use t equal
to two and go right so this is
completely kosher that's there's no
issue with act right what is not clear
is if you just give this operator or
give these three steps it's unclear if
they correspond to this operator what is
the initial conditions there is some
unclarity there's lack of specificity
[clears throat] and so it's important to
have this uh setting that I just
explained to you okay so what are this
is precisely the point that I'm trying
to say
yeah so this is uh in particular if you
have uniform time points it need not be
uniform but for notational simplicity
I [clears throat] put uniform time
points
what people often do is precisely what
you just said which is auto reggressive
rollouts so what is the meaning of that
so you pick a time point so this could
be this delta t that's why on purpose I
had something which is uniform so you
choose a uniform time point you know
that tk is equal to k * delta t where k
is your running index and then you
define your neural operator just to
predict the next step. Okay, so given a
time step TL, what the neural operator
does is that it predicts the next step.
So in other words, given the initial
conditions, I predict the first step and
then how do I go to the second step? I
take the first step and then march again
and do the second step. Then given the
second step, I march the third step,
fourth step and so on. Right? So this is
the idea behind this auto reggressive
rollouts. you keep on you you train the
operator to just predict for the next
time step. Okay, this is what a
numerical solver often does in a
numerical method. What we do is time
marching. Even for ODEs, right? You take
OD, you discretize in time. So given
initial time, you go to the first time
step. Given the first time step, you go
to the second time step, third time
step, fourth time step and so on. So
this is one way in which um a very
common way in which numerical analysis,
numerical methods for differential
equations work, right? And this is a
very very useful way. So all that you
have to do is to learn the next time
step and then auto reggressively apply
the operator. So is this clear what auto
reggressive rollouts mean? So you train
it for the next time step. You have a
large data set right? So and then what
you do is during inference I want to sit
at this I want you to predict this. So
you start with the initial conditions
apply it once apply it twice apply three
times four times five times. Right? And
similarly you keep on doing uh as you
do. So what is the problem? Well, this
is not usually it requires you can
modify it a little bit but uh in the
simplest setting it requires uniform
spacing because you have learned given
um given a certain input and given time
t equal to 1 hour what happens in 1
hour. You haven't learned what happens
in 2 hours. For 2 hours you need to
apply the 1 hour operator twice. But
what happens at 1 and 1/2 hours right?
Then how do you do this? So what you
have to do is you apply it from 0 to one
then go from one to two and then you
interpolate between one and two right
it's not a continuous uh evolution so it
requires uniform spacings and the main
issue is that you have error
accumulation what does it mean and this
is well known in numerical methods that
when you apply it once you make a
certain error when you apply it twice
the potential is that the error is
additive you have two times the error
three times the error and so on so this
is thought could be very very risky and
also there is no continuity because the
evaluation is at discrete time levels.
So as I said to go in between I have to
use interpolation.
So it is a little bit like the CNN plus
interpolation approach that we did. We
predicted a few time steps and then we
interpolate can be done if you have
sufficient uh density of points right
but that's that's not the main issue.
The main issue is actually the potential
for error accumulation, right? And this
uniform spacing, which is okay for
weather prediction because weather
prediction people are interested in what
happens in 1 hour, in 2 hours, and 3
hours. So weather predictors, AI based
weather predictors, emulators, they
usually do this kind of auto reggressive
rollouts. So to predict the weather in a
day, what they do is that they predict
the weather in 6 hours, then 12 hours,
18 hours a day. So this is a very very
common thing. But in general in
engineering and science this cannot be
done because you need solutions at
discrete time points and this this is an
issue. But this is very much a viable
option. The second viable option which
is what I would say is a better option
in some sense is what is called time
conditioning
because the issue here is that this was
just discrete and interpolation. Right?
This is much more of a continuous uh
time interpolation. I don't know why I
said CN O. It must be any N O, right?
Because uh why why CNO? Uh this applies
to anything. But maybe CNO was an
example. Okay, now I understand. So here
is CNO is an example. So what do we do
in time conditioning is that you use the
time itself as a input channel. Okay,
you use it as an input dimension. If you
remember my solution operator, okay,
there's so many things I've written. The
solution operator has time as an input,
right? So just we replicate that and use
time as an input also for the machine
learning task. Okay. So you want to put
uh time as an input. So what do you do?
You are given the solution at time t
and you're given the time or what is
called the lead time t bar means no one
gives absolute time. You can also give
it but in practice it makes a lot of
sense to give the lead time because you
don't know from where you're going to
march. Right? So given these two CNO or
any other neural operator CNO is shown
here for concreteness. What you do is
that you make a prediction which is uh s
you learn the solution operator which
given the current state
and given lead time predicts the
solution at the t plus uh t bar time.
Right? So this is really an
approximation to the solution operator
not by composition but directly. So that
is the sort of difference from the auto
reggressive rollouts. But the question
is how do we apply this time right? The
simplest way is just give it in the
beginning just like we give the initial
data or the inputs just give it in the
beginning in general that is okay but uh
after some experiments people realized
or we in particular realized that you
tend to forget. So just imagine that
instead just you give the input plus you
give the time lead time right and then
what happens is that you have 20 layers
here you have bottlenecks you have
residual connections you have all kinds
of funky things that are happening and
by the time you come to the bottleneck
the effect of time is the embedding of
time is somehow gone and uh the
causality the sort of temporal behavior
suffers can suffer huh in general this
is a viable option just put it as a lead
time so what people figured out is to
use uh normalizations
to put explicitly time after each layer.
So this is where and how do you do it?
Remember in machine learning you have
MLPS you have convolution or attention a
sort of an engine a kernel and you have
normalizations right? So this is the
structure that we have always dealt with
and in the you there's no point in
putting it in an MLP there's no point in
putting it in attention convolution.
These are time independent operations.
So where you put it is in the
normalizations. So what you do is
remember this is a layer normalization
for instance that the input is uh given.
So you take a mean over all the
channels, you take the variance and this
is the you [clears throat and cough]
usual sort of layer normalization that
you do right last lecture I explained
this in quite some detail and then in
addition to it you conditionally
normalize it with some time in
embeddings okay so these are this GN and
HN these are MLPS [clears throat] so at
every layer you are sort of giving time
as an input you give a time as an input
here time as an input here time as an
input here here here everywhere it
remembers that oh this is the lead time
that I'm going to predict on this the
lead time that I'm going to predict on
in general you can use MLPS but linear
layers suffice so you can just use some
matrix vector multipliers that that's
good enough and you can use all kinds of
normalizations depending on what
normalization is used layer norms batch
norms instance norms all of them can
have this right so it's a very simple
time conditioning layers and there is
quite some engineering that one can do
at these days people are using FIA
embeddings. So instead of just looking
at time itself they take some sign and
cosine of time and embed it thinking
that it will provide them better
frequency control on what's going on.
But this is a detail right this may or
may not give you any advantage but the
idea is to ensure that every part of
your machine learning pipeline sees the
input time. That is sort of the key key
point here.
Clear? So everyone understands how this
is to be done and I think bogdan has
explained this at some point in the
tutorial right this was done a little
bit ahead and I'm only coming to it now
yes go ahead
>> what's the difference to passing by
residual connections to
>> you could also do residual connections
but uh even those have to be normalized
right so everything has to be normalized
so it's sort of this is so that's the
logical way where you put this because
you don't want the convolutions to be
affected or attention to be affected by
this. So it makes sense to put it
through this. Okay. So then let's uh so
you have this so your operator. So there
are two strategies. You can do auto
reggressive or you can do time
conditioning. Auto reggressive there is
it's sort of plain vanilla. There's not
much to do right you have been given
solution. You just want to make next
time predictions and you keep on doing
that. With time conditioning you have a
richer sort of space to play with. And
this is what I would like to explain a
little bit what what is the richer space
to play with. So now training training
strategies right so there are different
kinds of training strategies. So
remember that uh the simplest okay let
me let me try to explain this so that
everything is clear. So this is my data
set right? So I have the entire
trajectory and of course this changes
with samples. This is just one sample
and remember I did not even put in the
velocity the velocity field the
coefficient right this is just the
displacement uh which measures the wave
behavior. So this is one sample and you
have many many samples thousands of
these kind of samples right or input
output target pairs. So now what does
one at a time training mean? What a one
at a time training is simply that what
you do is given the initial conditions.
This is not a good picture. So given the
initial so what do you do in training?
So you have u 0 u1
u0 u2
u0 u3
and so on. Right? So just take the input
output target pairs. As you see it
starts with u0 or u bar. Again, sorry
for the notational confusion here. Okay,
I can use this as zero, right? And then
U0 UK.
Okay, so these are your data pairs. So
all that you do is that here uh take
this two guys and tell the neural
operator that match given t equal to 1
and given this initial condition match
or try to fit this guy the target here.
Okay, so that would be your t equal to
1. Why is it not writing
here? Similarly, you do the same t= 2
you say that given the initial
conditions and time t equal to 2, I get
a certain output. Similarly, with t= 3,
t= 4 and so on. That's why I call it as
one at a time and these are the data
pairs and if you have k samples per
trajectory or k time snapshots per
trajectory, then you get k uh training
pairs, right? So a neural operator is
given k training pairs and if you have n
samples or n trajectories let's say
thousand you have thousand * k. So this
could be 20. So you have 20,000 data
pairs and you can train your neural
operator to work with this 20,000 pairs.
Right? So remember that this is
different from an auto reggressive
setting because in an auto reggressive
setting to go up to t equal to 5 I would
repeatedly apply the operator and this
is not so easy to train sometimes. So
usually in auto reggressive settings
people only train for the next time step
or maybe they take train two a roll out
strength of two but here you can take
any of it right you'll just say that at
t equal to 5 given my initial conditions
this is the solution match it right so
this is all that is happening here is
that clear so the number of data pairs
now is k * n where n is your number of
samples so if you have thousand samples
this is 20,000 which is which is quite a
lot right so in particular for the
weather. This could be a very very rich
set. But now this is not the only thing.
The real thing here and you could have
guessed what is going on is who stops me
from saying that I just start at the
initial conditions and predict solutions
at a later time. Any later time but at a
later time I can start at any time and
predict solution at any forward time.
Right? Because this is what a time
dependent operator can do. My solution
operator takes inputs at any time point
and predicts solutions at a later time
point. Why not use that for training?
And this is what is called an alltoall
training. This was this is a simple idea
but to the best of my knowledge it was
introduced by us a couple of years ago.
And what do you do in that? So we
essentially just do that right. So now
my inputs are any of the possible
combinations that you have. The only
assumption that I'm making is that it
should be causal. So I cannot say that
given t= 10 predict the solution at t
equal to 8. That would not be the
forward solution operator. That will be
the backward solution operator. So in
this case okay there is some it really
leverages this semigroup property right
of the solution operator. So now what
you do you can have u0 u1 u0 up to u k
all of these pairs they are very much
allowed right from the initial condition
you can measure anything but you can
also start at u1 and from u1 you can't
go to u0 but you can go to u2 you go
from u1 you can go to u3 you can go all
the way up to uk so all these pairs you
can see the writings there similarly
from u2 you can you can't go to u0 u1
but you can go to u3 you can go go to U4
and so on and so forth. Now you can see
how much of data we have at our
disposal. So what does the neural
operator or the operator the solution
operate you know the neural network what
is it trained for given the solution at
any time instant given a lead time it
matches the solution at the future time
and it takes all possible combinations
into account in in practice this is a
very very large set. So what happens now
is that instead of having just k samples
per trajectory you essentially have k
square samples per trajectory right so
earlier let's uh remember this that we
have we had 20 samples per trajectory we
had thousand trajectories right so we
have 20,000 data pairs now we have 20
samples but instead of 20 we have
actually 210 because it's 20 * 21x2
right so it's uh so you have 210 so now
instead of 20,000 you have 210,000
samples so a much richer database than
you had before and the task of the
neural operator gets harder. So it is uh
it's forced to generalize better because
now it has to learn how to match things
from uh you know from any unseen from
[clears throat] any point to any unseen
time point. Right? So this is sort of
the the main point here. So training can
be done like this with differently
times. Inference you can do directly or
auto reggressively. What does it mean at
inference? Maybe I explain it at
inference suppose you want to learn the
solution at t equal to 4 right. So the
by this method given any initial
condition given the initial condition
and given t equal to 4 I can predict the
solution because my solution reachs out
any time and any point right that is one
possibility but I can also do auto
reggressively because I I I know that I
can go from t=0 to t= 1 apply it again
to t= to 2 apply it again to three apply
it again to four but that's not the only
possibility I can also go from 0 to two
right because this is allowed. I can
learn from any time and then auto
reggressively compose it from two to
four or I can go from 0 to three and go
from three to four. I can go from 0 to
1, one to four. There are so many
possibilities that you can think of
right this is why it says it's multiple
possibilities and in particular you can
evaluate at any time including out of
distribution times including any not
unseen time horizons. So this is a very
very flexible strategy. Okay, is this
clear? Are there any questions? This is
a this is a subtle concept means uh so
one has to sort of do some examples
maybe in the projects we'll have some
examples where you can learn this
better. Okay. So now maybe we show some
results. So I so let me just summarize
before I before I show any results. So
what do we do? So for temporal problems
we have this uh trajectory based data.
So we have multiple we have more data to
play with. we have a harder task because
now we have to not just find the
solution at for a given input but for
any time point. So we can either use
auto reggressive training and inference
or we can use this kind of allto-all
much richer training with time
conditioning and inference which is much
richer. So both possibilities are there
many more in in between combinations but
both possibilities are also there. So
now let me uh before I show you the
results maybe it's time to take a very
very quick break today. Uh maybe I just
okay so now these are the different
strategies that we learned before the
quick break and see whether let's see
whether it works in practice or not. So
we come back to our familiar example. So
this is Navia Stokes equations right? So
Navia Stokes [snorts]
and the advantage here is that the
boundary conditions are periodic. So you
don't have to specify the boundary
conditions which makes life very very
simple. So then what do we do the the
task is given u not the initial
conditions or u bar whatever I called it
you find solution at any time t
from whatever zero to capital t.
>> Yes. Can we put the slides full screen?
>> Oh yeah,
>> it isn't full screen.
>> Yeah,
>> that was strange.
>> Okay, never mind. Okay, so the task is
uh and you remember this data set,
[music] right? So what I had shown you
before was simply the solution at the
final time. Now we have to look at the
solution as an entire trajectory. So let
us uh collect all the results that we
have here. So what is this? uh it
requires a little bit of uh work. So
let's look at this one. So this is uh
this is the same thing but in log scale.
So this is in the linear scale and this
is in log scale. So what you have here
is the test error. So the test error
tells you how much of error you make and
you're going all the way from half% to
10% roughly. Right? And this is the
number of trajectories. Now remember the
trajectories is not just the number of
time snapshots but the number of
trajectories that uh that you have in
the system right so we go all the way
from how much is this uh 8 is 256
trajectories to about 8,192
trajectories right but for each
trajectories we have this uh multiple
multiple multiple time snapshots I think
14 snapshots if I'm not mistaken and
these are what you see here are uh how
the error behaves at different times.
Okay. So as you can imagine as time goes
on you the error keeps on increasing
whatever be the strategy that you're
adopting the error keeps on increasing.
Let's fix let's say,024 trajectories
with t equal to0.2 so the beginning of
the evolution this is about 1%. Right?
At t = what is it 0.4 uh four the orange
one this is uh about 2% then it goes to
around 3% around 4% and at the end it's
about 5 to 6% right so the error is
always increasing as you as you have
more time this is not unexpected this is
same with numerical methods it is harder
uh to capture these particularly if you
have auto reggressive but in even the
direct evaluation but this error
increase is only linear in this case
it's not exponential this is what you
want to avoid right if it's exponential
you are finished so linear error
increase is sort of very very standard
this is what one would one would expect
and there is a secular belief in that
there's the first observation that you
have the second observation that you
have is that at any time as long as the
number of trajectories increases you
have very nice scaling of error so this
this always decrease right let's take an
example so from so this is at uh
approximately 2% and then when you go to
let's say four times that number is
approximately 1%. So 0.5. This is
exactly the same sort of scaling that
you get. The scaling is approximately
0.5. It's a little less than 0.5. So
this is very satisfactory. Error grows
in time. Error decreases with the number
of uh trajectories, the number of
training data that you have. Okay. The
second one and this is very very
interesting is um
okay. So let's let's try to focus again.
There is quite a rich uh set of results
here. So now what you do is when we
train this um operator this was based on
CNO but this the same kind of results
for every single neural operator that we
we have tested on right so what you do
is that you your trajectories your data
is sampled your training data so this is
this in input right so your training
data is at t equal to0 which we don't
write here 0.2 2 0.4 0.6 0.8 and 1.0.
Okay. So this is where your training
data is. Now the test data is not just
at these points but at any arbitrary
point in principle at any arbitrary
point. Just for simplicity we showed it
at uh the the other points the uniform
point 0.3 0.5 7 9 and so on and 0.1 in
the beginning you know there is a large
change. This can be fixed and this was
some preliminary results or old results.
This can be fixed by different uh let's
say sophisticated state-of-the-art
techniques but in the beginning you are
directly going from t equal to0 where
nothing happens to something
dramatically changing or something
changing large gradients. So the errors
are large. So you can you can just
dispense off. But then you can start
seeing that essentially from here
onwards the errors are almost it's as if
it is nicely interpolating between these
time points. So you can evaluate it at
any time point and the error behaves
exactly as it would behave as if you are
interpolating. Right? So in a way you
can think of it as a smart interpolation
but it is beyond that because it has
never seen this in the training data at
all. Right? So it has to get this
information from the dynamics itself and
which is not always obvious. It's not
guaranteed that this happens. So this is
precisely this continuous in time
property that has come. We can improve
it much further mean later on we have
improved it. But already at this level
you can see a manifestation of this
particular property that uh that you
have this sort of behavior here. So you
can see that uh the error is quite quite
well behaved. So it can be evaluated at
any point which is which is the key key
question or the key key issue here.
That's why we say it's O D time levels
right. Uh then this is an interesting
one. This is different inference
strategies. So remember that um [snorts]
yeah t equal to 1. So to go to t equal
to 1. So you start with uh you have t
equal to 0 0.1
or 0.2 rather 0.2 2 4
6 8 1 something like this. Right? So
what we do is that you have a direct. So
what does direct mean? Direct means that
to find the solution at t equal to 1 you
at inference you give it the initial
conditions and you give it time t equal
to 1 and read off. So as you can see as
the number of trajectories increases the
error secularly decreases and with
direct you have uh so these are some of
the rates that are there with direct
this is the error that you get right so
you get about 4% error with uh four 248
trajectories but remember I told you
that we why should we just use direct
that's the simplest the fastest in a way
because it's just one shot right you
just give it one time and then it finds
the solution here we have given
different kinds of things. So auto
reggressive would be because we have 10
snapshots here. So you start with zero
go to 0.1.2 0.3 and so on. So the auto
reggressive in this case is actually
better right just at inference but
remember that I also have to infer it 10
times now. So the inference itself is 1
millisecond. So 10 milliseconds doesn't
really matter in this application right
but auto reggressive as you can see it
does um clearly does better. It's
halfing the error. Why it happens who
knows mean it's sort of it's in this not
not even a is it a half or it's yeah
it's like 2% and 4%. So in this case
it's easier because to learn from 0 to
10 is not easy whereas to learn from 0
to 1 1 to 2 2 to 3 is easy and the error
accumulation that you get in this case
is less than the error that you're
making when you're doing a direct match.
Right? So this is one thing uh which is
is difficult to get a theoretical
guarantee on but this is an observation.
But now in this case the strategy that
works the best are the red and the green
lines. So for instance let's look at the
let let's look at the green line. This
is the one that gives you the best
error. It even halves the error
significantly. So what you do in the
green line is you go from 0 to one. Okay
we know that that's a hard thing to do
because in the beginning a lot of things
happen. So you go from 0 to 1 and then
from 1 to 4. So you go directly from 1
to 4, 4 to 7, 7 to 10, right? Means this
is the this is the strategy and this
gives you a much better error across all
the levels. This is based a little bit
on expert knowledge. You know that in
the beginning there's the initial layer
and then there is a smooth evolution. So
you do that. But actually even the
what didn't work is the 55. Well, it did
work but uh the other one is also
working which is go from d equal to 5
then two and three that that also works.
So there are different strategies that
you can try. So this is left to the end
user's choice right once the training
has been done it is at your uh choice to
see how you do inference right you can
do inference in an auto reggressive
manner you can do inference in a direct
mode or you can do inference somewhere
in between. Yes
>> to clarify is this all from as well
trained on the all to all.
>> This is with alt wall. This is with al.
>> Okay. So yeah, you said like it's start
with the
>> yes everything here that I'm saying is
about all to all
>> but in the next one I think I compare
the two but so far it's all to all
because it gives you the freedom right
it sort of tells you that you can use
this auto reggressive strategies uh in
an effective manner. Further questions?
No. Now here is a comparison between the
different training strategies. Okay. So,
so vanilla is one one at a time, right?
So, this was not vanilla, it's one at a
time.
And all to all is the strategy that I
showed you. And it's it gives you a lot
of it gives you some advantage, but it's
not a massive massive advantage. It
gives you some advantage. Let me show
you what. So, let's uh fix the number of
trajectories. The number of trajectories
is still the same. So, the data
generation costs are still the same
means uh it's exactly the same amount of
data. Let's look at this. So you have
um,024
trajectories and you're looking at the
solution at t equal to 1 probably in the
direct mode. Now I don't remember the
exact strategy here. So this is uh 0.5%
error or 5% error 5% error right uh and
then if you do the all toall training uh
this is with the all toall training with
a plain vanilla training you have about
uh 7% 8% error right so the error does
go down because you have more data now
the error does go down but it doesn't go
down by a huge factor it does go down
because you have more data intensity uh
and this is secular in the sense that
each time we have observed that you have
a steady decrease in error but the main
advantage of this is of course that you
can reduce the number of trajectories
because the data generation costs I can
tell you that uh at large scale maybe at
the very last lecture I'll show you some
mind-boggling numbers uh which are
almost at the chat GPT scale
the amount of the compute cost for data
generation is like thousand times or
10,000 times more than training the
model so it's sort of the there is
massive massive data generation cost. So
if you can save on data generation then
it's always a boon and this is what
really happens. So if you for instance
instead of,24 trajectories here if you
draw a line we are somewhere around 512
trajectories right. So you half the data
generation cost doesn't look like a lot
but at scale this is like a billion
dollars. So this is a real uh you know
it might not matter a lot but it does
matter at the end. Question. Um yes in
practical applications is there any
argument for not using all to all
>> uh storage
>> okay
>> uh it's not even that the model training
so I'm I'm sorry it's not storage per se
because uh you would you would anyway
have to store also for the other kind of
training right but I would say model
training costs
>> okay
>> because it it's more expensive to train
and
>> k square
>> uh it's k squared but in practice that's
a huge number so you know if you have uh
if you have 10,000 trajectories this a
huge number right so you 100 time steps
it's it's still a big number so what you
do is that instead of doing it k squ you
take a certain proportion of k squared
which you decide randomly right because
then you can randomly per epoch you can
change and then the training cost but
there is absolutely no reason to not do
it
you know because the training costs are
vastly dwarfed by data generation costs
but if your training costs uh means You
know not everyone has access to huge
supercomputers to train. So if you're
sitting with your little laptop and you
want to do training then you will
probably do what is the most effective
one which is not necessarily all to all
but some version of it where you
randomly sample because it makes sense
for a neural operator to make it
training task as hard as possible so
that it generalizes well right so this
is sort of the principle but anyway
coming to your point this is a very
interesting uh uh result it has a lot of
content in it so it uh it's important to
because now all to all as you said uh
the question was with all to all it's uh
there are so many things that you can do
right so for instance here what we show
there are there are a lot of things
forget about this auto reggressive and
direct right because this is just the
two modes of inference this is uh but
what is this t2 and t1 so t1 is uh you
do all to all but at a resolution of uh
all the 20 time snapshots or 14 time
snapshots that you So you take each of
these 14 time snapshots and you train 91
pairs. Whereas uh T2 is with seven of
them. Okay. So with seven of them which
means that you randomly not randomly but
you uniformly choose half of them and
then you just use all to all training on
that. So you reduce the number from 91
now to how much is 7 * 6 by 2. So 21 or
something right? So you reduce the
number by half and then you see that
there is some saturation means uh you
know these time trajectories are not
totally independent of each other. Only
in a completely chaotic system with no
memory will this be completely
independent of each other. But
essentially the information that is
contained particularly with very small
time increments is not a lot of
information. Okay. So what one what the
model trainer has to decide is what is
my effective resolution where I can
learn something useful and not burn my
training compute right so these are sort
of dynamic decisions that one has to
make and in this case it is that instead
of taking all the all to-all pairs if
you take half of them it's good enough
sometimes maybe 1/4 of them is good
enough so this is sort of a dynamic
thing and so that's the first thing that
there's a saturation just because you
keep on taking more data doesn't mean
that this data is uh that this is going
to lead to a decrease in performance or
something. Can anyone give me a
mathematical or a semi-mathematical
reason why this is the case? Because
what have we learned? We have learned
that more data when we randomly sample
from a distribution leads to better
performance. But in this case at some
level it gets saturated. Who can tell me
why? Yeah.
>> Well, from information theory as we draw
samples from a distribution it adds
larger information.
>> That is true. But here the these samples
are no longer iid. That's the main
reason. These are not independent
samples because they are highly
correlated to each other.
>> So if you take uh the information
content that is there in a 100 of them
is not double the or square root of two
times the information content in 50 of
them. It's much less because these are
not iid. So that's the main sort of
reason. But nevertheless there is some
information content right? it's not uh
the content between 100 and 10 is not
zero. There is some gain in information
but it's not a dramatic gain in
information. And the last point that I
want to make and then we can stop about
time dependent operators is a very
interesting one. So this is that so we
do the same thing here. So T14 so this
one is essentially so this is the direct
mode essentially. So what you do is you
just uh take this is what we were doing
before given the initial conditions just
find the solution at a final time right
so with that as you can see for instance
here the error was I don't know 20% with
512 samples okay in this particular
example now with the same data
generation pipeline of course with a
different model training pipeline what
we have learned with this all to all
with auto reggressive inference and so
on how much do we reduce the error
Right? So as you can see now with 512
here you go somewhere down here. Right?
So this is exactly the same quantity
that you're comparing but now it's the
cumulative strategies that we have
accumulated. So all to-all training auto
reggressive inference and when we
combine them we see that instead of 20%
we are at now 7 10 9 7 6 5 or something
5%. So we reduced it by a factor of four
right? So this is a massive gain in with
the same the data generation pipeline is
exactly the same but now by accumulating
this I reduce the error considerably and
not only that I also reduce the number
of uh trajectories that I need right so
for instance this was with 128
trajectories and is very very similar
error to the 512 trajectories so
essentially I can reduce the data
generation cost by a factor of four or
five so there is a benefit of doing all
this but it's not like a 512 times
benefit right it's a it's a moderate
benefit but as I told you at the top end
this 5 to 10 is a huge number so it's
very very important to have this
innovative strategies in place so I
think that's all I wanted to say about
time dependent problems I think you have
had a tutorial on this at some point
right it was not the one but the one
before I think CNO time dependent so you
can sort of reconnect with that and when
you deploy this in practice when you go
in in um in a lab or when you go and in
the job you remember that hey there are
different uh possibilities for using
time dependent uh training and
inference. Okay any questions? Yes. Go
ahead.
>> Active learning in some way used in
>> active learning. Yes. Yes. Yes. But not
in this context here. The interesting
thing that is coming on is what is
called online learning. So online
learning the the the difficulty with
time dependent data sets is you have to
store data right and you imagine that in
your experiment if you're generating per
time step terabytes of data then you
have to store and there is storage is
limited. So what people are doing now is
that they are experimenting with how to
sort of keep on learning the model
simultaneously with generating the data
and once this is uh there are some
preliminary attempts even we are
involved in some projects in this but
once this is sort of established then
this can be done at scale and can be
combined with active learning because
what active learning does maybe maybe at
the end of the uh course I have time to
come to active learning is to sort of
sum sample data in such a manner that
you have an objective which is achieved
which is to reduce the error for
instance right but if you have to store
all the data and then decide then this
becomes unaffordable so here in this
context online learning is more
important than active learning active
learning is anyway with any operator
learning this is an important important
point okay so now we go to the next
caveat uh which I'll just um start I'm
not really going to do a lot of work on
it but uh let's let's just start. So the
first caveat was time dependent problems
and as I said for time dependent
problems there are lots of solutions
which are available and you can really
uh augment or improve [clears throat]
your methods by doing many of these
tricks. [snorts]
But the second caveat and I'll spend
quite a bit of time on this is what
happens to PDEs but on arbitrary
domains. So, so far what we have shown
is something very very sort of cartisian
right I had examples everything was on a
unit squared and I showed you at least
it wasn't on a unit squared and not on
the unit interval but uh it's still on a
unit square right so in in principle we
were just doing problems like this so
far but engineering and uh especially
engineering sometimes physics but
especially engineering is not like that
right so look at this I don't know how
well you see it now you can see it well
so this is a flow passed an air foil
right so this is 2D 3D it's even more
complicated difficult to visualize you
see it in the next uh [clears throat]
example so this is an air foil and this
is where the data for the air foil comes
from right it comes from a numerical
simulation and the numerical simulation
understands or the person making the
numerical simulation understands that a
you cannot represent it on a cartian
grid because there are geometries here
right b that this grid has to be highly
adapted because there are some shock
waves, there are some different
features. So this is an actual example
of a mesh that was generated by one of
my students in our lab and you can see
how how dense or how different the data
format is. So remember here everything
was uniform. It has points on a square.
Now here [clears throat] the flow field
is given at these points you know at
these tiny tiny little points and you
can imagine there are lots and lots of
points in this region because a shock is
going to form in this region in this
region. So there is no uniformity
whatsoever. It tossed out immediately.
So whenever you do an engineering
application, you cannot work with
cartitionian grids. That is okay for um
you know learning about something. It's
okay to some extent to learn about
physics. But engineering is about real
world when the shapes are going to be
very very complicated. So whatever we
have done so far does not necessarily
apply in this setting. And here is a
real industrial scale example. This is a
actual model of a race car, right? And
you can see that uh this is just on the
surface because if I showed you the
volume then this would be complicated
but this can be aerodynamic forces when
the car is uh moving um because it's you
know the the air exerts a force on it or
it could be loadings right it could be
that someone is trying to put a hammer
into a car and try to break it means
both of them some sort of loadings and
now you can see how complicated the mesh
is mean this is for aerodynamic purposes
right so you have lots Lots of points
here, lots of points here on the tires
in the tail fin, right? This is a very
very complex distribution of points. So
input and output are going to be on
essentially point clouds, you know, very
very very unstructured meshes. So this
is sort of the main point here. So so
far our focus has been on something
completely different. It has been on
cartigian domains. So this uniform grids
but uh most real world PDs are on
arbitrary domains right uh like the
examples that I just showed you and the
they're discretized with very very
unstructured grids and ideally if you
could just treat point clouds that's the
best means you should not even have a
notion of a grid because to store these
things is quite expensive. So to convert
what we what we showed some preliminary
positive results on cartisian grades
perhaps time dependent or time
independent it doesn't make a difference
to this is a massive challenge right and
this is what is required in order to
scale AI to real world physics and
engineering applications and we need to
be able to handle such data so a little
bit in today's lecture but essentially
in the next lecture I'm really going to
cover this topic at some length right So
is the challenge clear? So you cannot
use now convolutions, we cannot use FIA
transforms. All of this gone, right?
Because it's very very they're all based
on a cartian transformers can be used
still, right? Because it's essentially
operations with respect to points. But
some of the tricks there are also gone.
So as I said, what is the available
methods? There are many, but uh we will
explain a few of them. So one thing that
we we can do is to sort of convert it
into a cartitionian domain through what
is called masking. So what does masking
imply?
Masking is uh let me explain it a little
bit here so that you get the context. So
it's true that my data which is given
from the numerical solver or from
measurements whatever is given on a very
complex point cloud like this. But once
the data is there I can always uh sort
of interpolate it into a cartisian grid.
So what I can do is okay I say fine I
have this data which is on a very rich
domain but let me just take a very
simple cartian grid just for
illustrative purposes I'm using 16
points right you cannot use 16 points in
practice [snorts]
but you can do whatever 64x 64 a
cartisian grid and I can superimpose a
cartian grid on this particular picture
right but what will happen to my domain
here means there is no flow inside this
the flow only happens on the outside you
mask it you simply say that there is a
mask a binary mask which says which says
that there is one on this uh domain
nothing happens on inside the air foil
and it's zero outside the air foil
things happen outside the air foil or
the other way around so this is masking
you can convert very many many things
into a cartition once it has been done
you can convert it into a cartitionian
domain and perhaps later on we'll show
you some examples of this but you can
easily see that this is very very un
nice right because the operator is not
well defined the resolution of the
geometry is not there if you do it
something with a race car then you'll
not be able to do this binary mask very
nicely so this is a cheat right can be
done maybe as a baseline but it never
provides satisfactory answers never
understands the geometry right so this
is uh one of the one of the issues of
course fn for instance uh means it's
based on a fia transform so if you
remember fn fn was uh right
[clears throat] so you have the 4y year
transform which is an integral right
it's whatever f ofx e to the 2 pi i kx
something like that dx right and so in
principle this is a well- definfined
object means fiery transform is defined
on any domain means nothing nothing
prevents us the reason why fn was
restricted to cartigian domains was
because of the fast evaluation through
uh fft only works in cartigian domains
you That's uh so if you if I want to
directly evaluate this integral for 4
year transform then this is order of m²
m is the number of points with fft you
have m log m right so this was the
reason why computational complexity was
reduced but uh you know in this paper
which we which came out a couple of last
year I think from lab what we showed is
that uh you can replace this with just a
numerical quadriure but the only reason
Why this quadrice works is because you
don't need too many fourear modes. So if
you remember in fn we never needed more
than 24 or 20 modes or something like
that right so we took a very complex
data set and we reduced it into 20 or 24
fa modes and then you operated on that.
So this can be done by using what are
called direct spectral evaluations. This
is often a baseline that we used but
again there is no geometric
understanding. It's still a cartisian
domain method that we are cheating by
simply evaluating the fiery transform uh
in that manner. So it's still a viable
option. But the option that is very
popular particularly in industry is what
are called graph neural networks. Okay.
Um my hope was to start with graph
neural networks today. But clearly I've
run out of time. So uh in the next
lecture we will give you a very sort of
a short introduction to graph neural
networks. I won't really have time to
explain this in graphic detail, pun
intended uh because uh the first of all
there will be a full tutorial on graph
neural networks. Second, David who is
going to teach uh AI for chemistry and
biology, he will also explain graph
neural networks. So I will go through it
very quickly, explain its uh advantages
and also its disadvantages and then in
the next lecture already switch gears
and go for a combination of graphs and
transformers that I believe is the right
approach for these problems. Okay. So
next lecture in the beginning the first
half is on graph neural networks. The
second half is on a combination of
graphs and transformers that that sort
of solve some of the problems of graph
neural networks.